i think
this conversation is going to continue
for quite a while uh
michael has a new book on the topic
coming out eventually
one day so you're working also on uh the
still called dwight pill the white pill
yeah
and the first line of the white pill is
ein rand did not laugh i'm not joking
that's literally the first line
believe it because it opens up with her
who knows what the book's going to look
like when it's done but as of now that's
the beginning
because it opens up with her um
testimony at the house on american
activities committee
where she's trying to explain to these
congress people with communism
what it was like when she left the
soviet union
and they are just befuddled by it can
you explain she did not laugh
well because the first line the
fountainhead spoiler alert is howard
rourke laughed
so this is a little inversion of that it
says ayn rand did not laugh
because she had this she ayn rand was a
huge
fan of america as am i uh she was she
took
our political system very seriously
she had enormous reverence for
institutions one example of this
is one of the villains of the atlas
shrugged is based on harry truman
i think thompson is the character's name
and because she had such respect for the
name
for the title of president she refers to
him as the chairman she couldn't even
bring herself she had a huge respect for
the for the presidency yeah i wonder if
she'd still have it right maybe
the last string of presidents so having
her
which sets up the broader point of the
book which i'm sure i'll be
back on the show discuss assuming this
bridge hasn't been burned but i'll try
my best
um all three of us are cancelled some
is how uh ignorant
many people are in the west about the
horrors
of stalinism and communism but also
how many people in the west were
complicit
in saying to americans go home
everything's fine this is great
sure you know this is why pence have a
race to show their mistakes
and they really made a point to downplay
really gratuitously
some of the unimaginable atrocities
of of the communism and just one more
sentence
and going through the work and learning
about what they actually did
is so jaw-dropping that
it's and i if i didn't know about it
many people i'm friends with who are
historians who are entering the space
that you know this isn't common
knowledge to them
then we can assume that almost no one
knows about it and i think it's very
important
uh for people to appreciate whether
republican democrat liberal whatever
uh how much of a danger this is
and i think americans have this there's
a book called it can't happen here
i think by uh sinclair lewis about a
fashion come to america
we american exceptionalism has a
positive
context but also have a negative context
where you think we're invincible
all these horrible things other
countries that can't possibly happen
here we're america we're special
and it's completely an absurdity yeah
yeah have you seen the movie mr jones uh
my friend wrote it um no i haven't but
walter durrante
and his quotes i have a threat on
twitter walter durrante for those who
don't know
he won a pulitzer because he was uh the
new york times man in moscow
and endlessly he was talking about
how great it was how if you hear about
this
famine in ukraine this is just
propaganda i went to the villages
uh you know everyone's happy and fed a
lot of it was
explicit lies you know and when you
realize you're talking about
let's give them the absolute benefit of
doubt and accidental genocide
it's still um mind-boggling and also
you know ann applebaum who's just a
phenomenal
phenomenal writer she wrote a book
called red red famine stalin's war in
ukraine
and she talks about how what people in
america appreciate
is how uh clever in their sadism
the soviets were and what they knew to
do to ukraine is
everyone is starving so they knew if you
got some meat on your bones
you're hiding food yeah so they come
back at night take your hand put in the
door jam keep slamming the door
ransack your house they didn't have to
find the food
burn down your house take all your
clothes goodbye and good luck
i don't recall saying good luck yeah it
is so it's just so i highly recommend
uh the movie because it's very well done
okay it's very well directed it's
beautifully made
it's it's stunningly effective
okay and illustrating exactly that the
scenes in ukraine
during the famine oh your heart i mean
it's just
it's crushing it's so and it shifts to
black and white it's very
very well made aesthetically so highly
recommend and it's written by andrew
chalupa she's a ukrainian
um friend of mine she introduced me
janmi park who's a big north korean
defector
um and and uh it's it's this is this is
the kind of thing where i think more
people need to
one when i wrote the new write which
talks a lot about
the nazis or the the kind of neo-nazis
one of their big complaints
about you know against uh people who are
jewish she's like oh we hear
all about the holocaust you how come you
don't talk about holiday more i'm like
i'm trying to do my part
i agree with you yeah that we need to
talk about absolutely
and it's it and it's it's sad there not
more movies that are anti-soviet which
tells you a lot about
the view of the intelligentsia it's a
great idea it just was badly implemented
and no it's a rotten idea it's an evil
idea and it was implemented
exactly it was implemented exactly how
it has to be implemented there's no
alternative
you